السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في وقفتنا
التحليليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوميه في كلمه مسجله حصلت عليها الجزيره
اكد ابو عبيده الناطق باسم كتائب القسام
ان استمرار العدوان لا يسمح باطلاق سراح
الاسرى واضاف ان العدو اذا اراد اسراه
احياء فليس له من خيار سوى وقف
العدوان لذلك اذا اراد العدو
وجمهوره اسراهم احياء فليس امامهم سوى وقف
العدوان والدخول في التفاوض بمسارات
المعروفه عبر
الوسطاء وهذا موقف ثابت ولا بديل عنه سوى
استمرار تساقط اسرى العدو قتلا بنيران
جيشهم المتغطرس وبقرار من قيادتهم ياسيه
التي تهرب من مواجهه الحقيقه والاعتراف
بها اذا مازلنا على مستوى ما يوصف ربما
بحرب الصوره
وحرب الوعي والاقناع بين كتائب القسام
وبين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما انه
يوما بعد يوم تتسع الهوه بين المواقف
الرسميه والشعبيه في الدول الداعمه
لاسرائيل لا سما في الولايات المتحده التي
من فكت ادارتها تجدد التزام بما تسميه حق
اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها رغم ابدائ من
وقت الى اخر تحفظات على ادائها في الحرب
على غزه وعلى توجهات وسياسات لحكومتها
شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه نقلت عن تحليلات
اجرتها وكالات الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان
مصداقيه حماس ونفوذها تناميا بشكل كبير
منذ هشوم السابع من اكتوبر وبدء الرد
العسكري الاسرائيلي عليه الشبكه الامريكيه
نقلت ايضا عن من سم تهم مسؤولين مطلعين
قولهم ان حماس نجحت في وضع نفسها في اجزاء
من العالم العربي والاسلامي بوصفها مدافعه
عن القضيه الفلسطينيه ومقاتله فعاله ضد
اسرائيل كما نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين
القول انهم يراقبون العديد من المؤشرات
التي توضح ان دعم حماس تزايد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وفي اماكن اخرى بالمنطقه موقع
بوليتيكو نقل من جانبه عن استطلاع اجرته
جماعه كوين بياك الامريكيه ان الامريكيين
يشعرون بالاستياء من دعم بلادهم لاسرائيل
بعد شهرين ونصف من حربها على غزه ووفقا
لاستطلاع لهذا الاستطلاع فان نسبه مؤيدي
ارسال المزيد من المساعدات العسكريه الى
اسرائيل قد تراجعت من
54% الشهر الماضي الى 45% فقط هذا
[موسيقى]
الشهر كتائب القسام بثت في اطار مساعيها
لكشف اخطاء اداء اسرائيل في الحرب بثت
مقطعا فيديو مقطع فيديو جديد يظهر صورا
لثلاثه من الاسرى الاسرائيليين دا حركه
حماس قالت انهم قتلوا على ايدي الجيش
[موسيقى]
الاسرائيلي
ا
[موسيقى]
معنا في هذه الحلقه من خان يونس الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اياد القار هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور لقاء مكي الباحث الاول
في مركز الجزيره للدراسات ومن الخليل
الدكتور بلال الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الخليل اهلا بكم جميعا
نبدا بالاستديو دكتور لقاء مكي واضح تماما
ان ما يوصف ربما بحرب الصوره ليس اقل
ضراوه من الحرب في الميدان
توازيها واحيانا تمهد لها او تستفيد منها
وربما تتفوق عليها في بعض الاحيان الحرب
النفسيه ومنها الدعايه هي جز جزء اساسي من
عمل الجيوش ولذلك هي حمله وليست مجرد اليه
معينه حمله واسعه تش من كل شيء الاقتصاد
والدعايه وسواها لكنها تعتمد على نتائج
الميدان ان كان الجيش منهزم فهو لا يستطيع
ان يخلق حاله نصر ربما لفتره من الزمن لكن
ينكشف في لحظه لاحقه وهذا ما حصل مع
اسرائيل اسرائيل في هذه الحرب تحديدا في
حرب على غزه
ا خسرت مجمل التها الدعايه التي بنتها على
مدى 70 سنه اسرائيل تعتمد على مرتكزات
اساسيه في الدعايه منها اولا المظلوميه
انها هي ضحيه الظلم عبر التاريخ
الهولوكوست كاليه وبالتالي وظلمها من
الارهاب الارهاب العربي الثاني هو النجاح
كارض الاحلام الديمقراطيه الوحيده في
الشرق الاوسط دوله ناجحه اقتصاديا وسياسيا
وبالتالي هي تستحق الدعم الغربي والاحترام
الغربي والثالثه انها دوله محبه للسلام
لكن العرب يرفضون السلام هي تريد السلام
تريد الاجتماع الفلسطينيين ليس لديهم
مفاوض وهذه طبعا الاليه حتى المستوطنات
لديها اليه معينه لتمريرها وشرعنتها هذه
كلها فشلت في هذه الحرب من ناحيه هي لم
تعد دوله احلام ودوله ديمقراطيه شاهد
العالم كيف تدمر وتقتل المدنيين بهذه
الطريقه الانتقاميه البشعه وهي ثانيا لم
تعد مظلومه اصبحت ظالمه وثالثا هي لم تعد
تريد السلام لانها تمارس الارهاب بشكل
واضح وعلني على هذا الاساس في الواقع
اسرائيل خسرت الروا روايه سرديه الحرب
خسرت معركه الوعي ولذلك نرى ان الغرب الذي
خدع او اقتنع بالروايه الاسرائيليه ل 70
سنه مضت لا سما ان الاعلام الغربي مجبل
مؤيد لاسرائيل اصبح الان انتفض حتى الصحف
المؤيده لاسرائيل معروفه بتقليدي علاقتها
مثل واشنطن بوست علاقتها باللب الاسرائيلي
قويه لكنها لا تستطيع ان تتجاهل الحقائق
دوما لا بد وان تنشر شيء عن ما يجري هذا
الامر حرك الراي العام الشعبي والسياسي
ولذلك بدا الغضب على اسرائيل لذلك اسرائيل
تخسر حرب الصوره لانها بالاساس فشلت في
الميدان وارادت الانتقام من الميدان الذي
فشلت به بقتل المدنيين فخسرت في الجانبين
هل هل الدكتور بلال الشوبكي هل ما قاله
الان دكتور لقاء مكي هناك وعي به ولو
نسبيا داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
يعني ان كنا نتحدث عن المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بصفته يعني الشعبيه لا اظن ان هناك يعني
ادراك ل لحقيقه ما يجري الان في من رسائل
اعلاميه يمكن ان توجهوا متاثرين متلقين
لكن على مستوى النخبه الاسرائيليه وصناع
الراي وصناع القرار هناك ادراك حقيقي
لخطوره الصوره وان هناك ليست مجرد فقط
يعني تاثير نفسهم يكرروا عباره ان جزء من
الحرب النفسيه هي الصور التي تبثها كتائب
القسام مثلا لكن الامر تجاوز بالاضافه الى
ما تفضل به الدكتور لقاء مكي من التاثير
النفسي على الاسرائيليين الى محاوله يعني
التعمق اكثر في هذا التاثير برايي انه هذه
الصور انتقلت من مرحله الى اخرى او
الفيديوهات التي بثت من كتائب القسام
والمعلومات وال كل الماده الاعلاميه التي
تقدم لتصل الى مرحله اولا يعني زرع الشك ل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ودون ان يعي هذا
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بالضروره الاهداف
العميقه لمثل هذه الرسائل زرع الشك لدى
المجتمع الاسرائيلي في قدره مجلس الحرب
والمؤسسه العسكريه على تحقيق اهدافها من
خلال يعني مجموعه من الرسائل المكثفه في
هذا الصدد والتي تبث بشكل يومي المساله
الثانيه هي ال زرع الارتباك في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي ليس محصن من
الناحيه الاعلاميه بمعنى انه ان هو يتلقى
المعلومات و على تواصل دائم مع ما يجري
خارج دائره المعركه وبالتالي كل هذه الصور
التي تصل ويتداولها بالاضافه الى ما يعيشه
هذه تدفع الى الارتباك وهذا ما حصل ربما
او جزء من تفسير ما حصل مع اطلاق النار
على ال المحتجزين لدى الفصائل الفلسطينيه
بالاضافه الى هذا الموضوع ال الاخطر من
وجهه نظر الكثير من الخبراء الاسرائيليين
وهذا الذي يعكس وعيهم الان لهذه الصوره ان
ال الفيديوهات التي تبث من فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه عملت على ثلاثه مستويات
المستوى الاول مستوى الدفاع بمعنى في
المراحل الاولى من الحرب كان هناك خطاب
وفيديوهات تشير الى انسانيه الفلسطيني
والى ابطال امكانيه دع شنه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه من خلال مجموعه من الفيديوهات
التي كانت كثافتها في مرحله اطلاق سراح
المحتجزين لتبطيل الروايه الاسرائيليه
التي قدمت حول الفلسطيني المستوى الثاني
وهو مستوى الهجوم مستوى الهجوم ان كثير من
التسجيلات والفيديوهات كانت موجهه بشكل
واضح ومباشر للمجتمع الاسرائيلي من ا من
اجل زياده تماسك الفئه التي تعارض اسلوب
مجلس الحرب في اداره الحرب على قطاع غزه
نعم وهذا نشهده في التاثيرات الان لهذا
لهذه الفيديوهات المستوى الثالث وهو مستوى
الردع وهذا بدا في اخر 24 ساعه بالامس تم
نشر تسجيل او بث تسجيل حول امكانيه
التصنيع الموجوده لدى قطاع غزه وهذا يعني
ان الرساله الاخرى هي لكل الاطراف بما
فيها المجتمع الاسرائيلي حول قدره الفصائل
الفلسطينيه على الاستمرار في العمليه
العسكريه وبالتالي ابطال قدره اسرائيل على
التهديد والتلويح بامكانيه استمرار الحرب
لامد اطول نعم طبعا اهالي غزه سيد اياد
القاره يعني منهمكون
في معاناتهم اليوميه على الصعيد ال ال
غارات وتدبر شؤون الحياه ولكن مع ذلك هل
هل تراهم معنيين بحرب الصوره او بما يبثه
ابو عبيده او بما تبثه اسرائيل او هذه
الحرب على على وعي الناس و عقول
الناس صحيح قبل قليل حينما كانت كلمه ابو
عبيده كان هناك من خلال المتابعه الاذاعه
والقنوات الفضائيه لل الخطاب الذي بثه
الابو عبيده كان اهتمام كبير باعتبار انه
يمكن ان نسمي البوصله التي تعطيهم الاتجاه
الى اين تذهب الاحداث وخاصه في ظل انقطاع
الاتصالات وانقطاع الانترنت عمليا
ويتابعوا مثل هذه الخطابات ليعرفوا الى
اين الامور تسير بهذا الاتجاه وخاصه يمكن
ان نسميه اصبح شكل من اشكال التعاقد
الدائم ما بين الخطابات او الافلام التي
يتم بثها و بين الجمهور بحيث انه هي
القناه الرئيسيه لمتابعه الاحداث ومعرفه
ما الذي يدور في
الميدان لكن هذا ايضا بنفس الوقت ينعكس
ايجابا وموقف اكثر يمكن ان نقول اكثر صلاب
ويمكن ان نسميه تمتين الساحه الفلسطينيه
وهو جزء من الخطابات التي يتم التعامل
معها نحن نتحدث بتقديري عن اربعه اتجاهات
يتم العمل فيها في اتجاهين الاتجاه الاول
انه حماس تبنت بناء الصوره بحيث انه ركزت
بالش بالشكل الاساسي من من السابع من
اكتوبر على تمتين الجبهه الداخليه وقوه
المقاومه منذ اللحظه الاولى حتى اليوم في
السياق المقابل كان هناك محاوله اسرائيليه
هي كابوس الصوره بحيث انه اليوم الجمهور
الفلسطيني يدرك ان اسرائيل تبحث عن صوره
نصر حتى الان لم تحصل عليها وهذا له صدى
اليوم اليوم وبالامس كان هناك حديث كثير
بين المحللين الاسرائيليين وحتى صحفها
معاريف وهارت و معاريف ودعت احرنوت كان
بشكل واضح الى اين نحن ذاهبون صوره
اسرائيل تشوه بالعالم الرئيس الفرنسي تحدث
عن ذلك رئيس وزراء كندا تحدث بهذا الاتجاه
وانه اسرائيل تفقد عمليا الشرعيه الصوره
على مستوى العالم مما ترتكبه من مجازر
لذلك القسام يولي بشكل اساسي وحركه
حماس الجمهور الداخلي وضعه بالصوره اول
باول بما فيها ما يتعلق بالمفاوضات ما
يتعلق بالفيديوهات وهي ذات وقع بطم ديري
مهم عند المواطن
الفلسطيني يعني اولا هو يعايش الظروف وجزء
مهم منهم هم يشاهدوا احيانا هذه
الاشتباكات ويشاهدوا هذه الفيديوهات
ويستمع لهذه الاحداث لذلك بنى لديهم صوره
كما قلت شكل من اشكال التعاقد في متابعه
الاخبار ومتابعتها حتى حينما غاب خطاب
القسام لمده 12 يوم كان هناك تساؤل كبير
بهذا الاتجاه لذلك اعتقد انه حركه حماس
رغم كل الظروف التي تعرضت لها اضافه الى
مكينتها الاعلاميه لكن عملت بهذا الاتجاه
لبناء صوره في مواجهه اسرائيل التي تعيش
كابوس الصوره بحيث انه الناطق باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي على مدار الاسابيع 11 اسبوع لم
يتمكن من تقديم صوره حقيقيه هناك كثير من
الدلائل على ذلك الصوره التي حاولت
اسرائيل ان تبنيها في مستشفى الشفاء فشلت
في ذلك صوره الانفاق التي كانت اكتشف
الجميع انها عمليا عن اكذوبه وهذا ما قاله
ابو عبيده قبل قليل فيما يتعلق بقتل الم
المدنين واعدام المدنيين الفلسطينيين ايضا
ثبت انه اسرائيل كاذبه بذلك ايضا خطاب
اسرائيل تغير بين 7 اكتوبر حتى اليوم انت
لاحظ كان يستخم كلمه بشنه حماس اليوم لم
يعد يطرحها لهذا السبب لانه اصبح معروف
انه ان حماس ليست داعش وانه حماس حركه
مقاومه وطنيه فلسطينيه نعم مجموعه مجموعه
الاكاذيب التي اشرت اليها نسال عنها
الدكتور لقاء
مكي في البدايه كان الاعلام الامريكي وال
والاوروبي وخاصه الفرنسي والالماني على
قدر كبير من ال من التعبئه المواليه
لاسرائيل
احيانا بطريقه حتى مضحكه يعني مثلا بعض
المذعين في في في في برامج تلفزيونيه
قالوا بان الذين السيدات الذين لا يحملن
اولاد قتلهم مجرد دم ليسوا ليسوا حقيقيين
هذا في في الاعلام الفرنسي تخيل الاعلام
الامريك
ايضا كله معبا لكن الان بدانا نشهد نوع من
التحول يعني مثلا خاصه سي انان التي اشرنا
اليها قبل قليل عندما
استطاعت المراسله كلاريسا وورد الدخول الى
غزه ولو لفتره وجيزه اعدت
تقريرا سلطت فيه الضوء على المعاناه ثم
الواشنطن بوست التي اشرت اليها قبل قليل
اشرت الى ان موضوع مستشفى الشفاء مساله
غير غير مقنعه صحيفه ليبر الفرنسيه التي
عددت ببحث استقصائي مجموعه الاكاذيب حول
ما جرى في السابع من اكتوبر هل تعتقد
باننا بدانا فعلا في منعرج اعلامي اكثر
اكثر واقعيه اولا الصحفيين حول العالم لا
سما في الغرب لا نستطيع ان نجزم او نقول
انهم عملاء لاسرائيل يعني يتقاضون مقابل
الكذب هذا اعتقد فيها نظريه مؤامره مبالغه
كبيره هناك البعض متعاطف جدا والبعض تبني
للقضيه الصهيونيه لكن هذا يمثل فئه محدوده
حقيقه الفئه الاكبر هم صحفيين مقتنعين
بالروايه الاسرائيليه ومؤمنين بها لانهم
تربوا في ظل مناخ مؤيد لاسرائيل هم جزء من
مجتمع نخب ثقافيه وفكريه تعلمت ان اسرائيل
دوله مظلومه تمكنت من تاسيس كيان ديمقراطي
في بيئه دكتاتوريه ومستبد وانها تريد
السلام والعرب ارهابيين هذا هو
المخيال الغربي ل ماهيه اسرائيل لذلك
الصحفيين هم جزء من ها الاليه
والدبلوماسيه العامه الاسرائيليه اللي
تتولاها وزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
اسرائيل ما عندها وزاره اعلام وزاره
الخارجيه هي تتولى مساله
الدعايه تمكنت فعلا من بناء لوبيات قويه
وسط وسائل الاعلام الغربيه والنخب
السياسيه ولا سما في الولايات المتحده
فتمكنت من مجاراه هؤلاء يعني مكنت من
ايصال رسالتها الان
بداوا يرون الامر مختلف يعني حينما يرى
الصحفي بعينه ما يجري لا يستطيع ان يخرج
من جلده المهني فقط ليرضي اسرائيل حتى لو
بالتهديد لذلك نرى ان كثير من الصحفيين
المرموقين بداوا بالكتابه بشكل اخر حتى
فريدمان وهو صهيوني حاول ان يقول لاسرائيل
من البدايه كفى ان ذاهبين الى النهايه
لانه هذا غلط ارجوكم الهجوم البري مثلا
حذر منه لانه ي يرى ان الا امر يعني اصبح
عكس ما تريده اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بالصوره
او سوى الصوره اعتقد ان الاعلام الغربي في
هذه الحرب واحد من المكاسب المهمه
للمقاومه انها تمكنت من تغيير
المخيال الانطباع الصوره
المنطبق اللي كانت تسمى ارهاب هذا بحد
ذاته فوز عظيم بغض النظر عن نتائج المعركه
انتصار كبير يحسب للمقاومه حقيقه للصمود
الفلسطيني وبالتالي هذه الدماء انا اقول
يعني رغم رغم رغم يعني معزه هذه الدماء
وغلاوتها لكنها لم تذهب سدا ابدا يعني بغض
النظر عن نتائج الحرب هذه الدماء لم تذهب
سدا بالحقيقه هي كرست مفهوم المقاومه
ووضعت اسرائيل في خانه المتهم وهذا الامر
سيمتد لسنوات طويله وبالمناسبه ليس فقط
الاعلام الغربي الرؤيه العربيه للمقاومه
تغيرت اصبح العربي لم يعد يائسا اصبح
التحرير تحرير فلسطين ممكن لاول مره من 70
سنه على فكره حتى المتحفظين على الحركات
الاسلاميه لم يعودوا ينظروا الى حماس على
انها حركه اسلاميه بالنسبه اليهم هي حركه
مقاومه اي اي بعد ايديولوجي هذا ليس ليس
وقت الحديث عنه طبعا ليس وقت الحديث ثم
انه اذا كانت حركه اسلاميه تمكنت من تحقيق
هذا فاهلا وسهلا يعني هذا الميدان يعني
اذهب وقاتل يعني يعني المقاومه الفلسطينيه
خلال منذ الستينات قدمت الكثير الحقيقه
يعني هناك تراكم تراكم جهادي لكن الان
احنا في هذه المرحله عمليه الياس من تحرير
فلسطين الان اذا ما تلاشت فهي تراجعت هناك
ايمان حقيقي بانه هناك فرصه اصبحت
والمقاومه هي الحل شكرا جزيلا نعم ولهذا
الكتور بلال الشوبكي احدهم كتب ذات مره
شكرا لاسرائيل لانها في كل مره تتراجع
فيها القضيه الفلسطينيه ويظن البعض بانها
لم تعد على اجنده العرب تاتي اسرائيل بشيء
ما تجعلها تعود وبقووه ايه فيما يتعلق
بصوره النصر هذا التعبير الذي يستعمل
كثيرا في في اسرائيل الان الكل يبحث عن
صوره للنصر يستطيع من خلالها ان يقول خلص
ان انتصرنا لم ينجحوا الى حد الان في هذه
الصوره بينما حركه حماس تقدم ما ممكن ان
نسميه صوره المقاومه هذه المفا بين صوره
نصر غير موجوده وصوره مقاومه مجسده كيف
تراها اراها حقيقه تعكس
يعني فراد هذه التجربه وهذه الحرب الاخيره
و معركه طوفان الاقصى بمعنى انه في هذه
الحرب تحديدا الكثير من المفاهيم والكثير
من الانطباعات تغيرت وبالتالي اصبحت كلمه
النصر والهزيمه تحتاج الى اعاده نظر بمعنى
انه يعني انا اعلم ان هناك صعوبه لدينا
كمحلل ومراقبين ان نتحدث عن مفاهيم نصر
وهزيمه في ظل كل هذا الدمار الذي نراه لكن
ما حصل حقيقه ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المقاومه في قطاع غزه استطاعت ان تحقق
مجموعه من الانتصارات في مجال الوعي وهذا
لا يمكن قراءته الا بمراجعه الارضيه التي
ظهرت فيها هذه الحرب اولا كنا نشهد يعني
حال من الموت السريري للقضيه الفلسطينيه
على المستوى العربي الشعبي لم تعد القضيه
الفلسطينيه حاضره بل في بعض الاحيان اصبح
هناك خطاب شيطن للفلسطيني ب يعني دفع موجه
من قبل الكثير من الجهات وبالتالي يعني
بتنا نشهد فعلا حاله من الانعطاف حتى في
المواقف الشعبيه وليس فقط في المواقف
الرسميه وان كانت بشكل محدود المساله
الثاني انه كان هناك عمليه يعني اعاقه اي
لاي اي جهود فلسطينيه لتقديم مبادرات
جديده من اطراف اقليميه وكان هناك محاوله
للالتفاف حتى على القرارات الفلسطينيه من
يعني دول في الاقليم لذلك جاءت هذه ال هذه
العمليات وهذه الصور ليس فقط لتعيد
الطاوله لتعيد القضيه الفلسطينيه على
الطاوله العربيه وعلى وتعيدها كقضيه حيه
امام الشعوب العربيه وانما بالانتقال من
دائره التعاطف الى دائره محا وت ان يكون
هناك جهد عربي بمعنى ان المساله لم تبقى
في سياق العمليه التضامنيه وهذا لم يقتصر
فقط على الراي العام العربي برايي الاهم
كان في التطورات حتى في الراي العام
الغربي وهذه هي صوره الانتصار الاكبر
للفلسطينيين في هذا المشهد بمعنى انه في
اي حاله يتعرض فيها مدنيون للاذى
والاضطهاد عاده ما يكون هناك تعاطف على
المستوى العالمي هذا برايي وصلنا اليه
كفلسطينيين في مرحله مبكره من عمر هذه
الحرب لكن الاهم من ذلك انتقال هذا
المستوى من التعاطف الى مستوى ضاغط على
الحكومات وهذا يمهد الى حركه تغيير في في
الراي العام على المستوى العالمي بما فيها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لانه ما يعرف
من خصائص الراي العام مثلا في بلدان غربيه
ان الشريحه المؤثره هي الراي العام الفطن
وهذه محدوده جدا الان الراي العام المتقلب
اللي وهو الذي يتغير عاده بتغير الصوره
وبتغير المفاهيم بدا يشهد نوع من الثبات
والاستقرار على مدار الاسابيع الماضيه
لصالح الفلسطينيين في المقابل تحاول
اسرائيل ان تلملم صوره ما تقدمها اولا
للعالم على انها ما زالت ضحيه وفشلت في
ذلك من خلال التضليل وتحاول ان تقدم صوره
انتصار للمجتمع الاسرائيلي وهي تقلص من
اهدافها الان باتجاه الذهاب الى محاوله
اغتيال شخصيات فلسطينيه بعدما عجزت عن
تقديم صوره حقيقيه نعم حرب الصوره سيد
اياد القار ايه كما اصطلح على تسميتها لم
يساهم فيها فقط لم تساهم فيها فقط
المقاومه او او اسرائيل ساهم فيها الشباب
الفلسطيني والصحفيون الفلسطينيون العاملون
في في غزه بشكل كبير هؤلاء الشباب الذين
كانوا يعدون فيديوهات
ويرسلونها الى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هذه الحركيه هل تعتقد بانها ساهمت بشكل
كبير طبعا الى جانب العمل الصحفي ل للعديد
الذين دفعوا حياتهم ثمنا لهذه التغطيه انا
اليوم
صحيح انا يمكن نسميهم مقاتلين فعلا
مقاتلين بالكاميرا وبكلمه وبتسجيل وبالصوت
وفعلا انا نعايشه يوميا منذ اللحظه الاولى
كانوا اولا نقلوا الصوره الانسانيه
ل لما يقوم به الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
جرائم وصلوا الى مناطق خطره جدا ارتقى ما
يقارب 100 شهيد من العاملين في المجال
الاعلامي من صحفيين سواء بشكل مباشر او
غير مباشر و وبينهم هم الزميل سامر ابو
دقه مصور قناه الجزيره التي كان في احد
ميادين نقل الماساه التي يقوم بها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبتقديري هناك تحول
من خلال متابعتنا ومعرفتنا تفاصيل العمل
الاعلامي على مدار منذ عام 2008 و2012 و1
و21 وال عمليا في 23 وما بينهم كان هناك
عمل اليوم فلسطيني يمكن ان نسميه صاحب
رساله واضحه الرساله الواضحه تركز بشكل
اساسي على جرائم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكن
هنا ايضا اسمح لي ان اعود الى تحدث به
الدكتور لقاء في موضوع بناء الصوره بمعنى
انه مهم الصوره الانسانيه وهذا مؤثر على
الصعيد الدولي لكن بالاساس يجب ان نعود
الى السابع من اكتوبر والصوره التي بنيت
للاجيال العربيه انه هذا الكيان يمكن
هزيمته وانه عمليا هؤلاء الجيش هو عباره
عن العصابات التي هي ارتكبت المجازر في ال
47 و 48 في دير ياسين وفي بيت في لقيا وفي
نحالين وارتكبوا كل هذه المجازر هو ذاته
لم يتغير شيء عمليا بدل ان كان يستخدم
الذبح والقتل والحرق اليوم هو عمليا
يستخدم الطائرات الامريكيه اف 16 واف 25
هذه الصوره بتقديري قام الاعلاميون
الفلسطينيون بنقلها بشكل واضح وبشكل دقيق
لان عمليا وقائع صعبه وقاسيه حتى اليوم
زارت ا تحدث الليله الماضيه عائله كامله
22 فارد من اسره واحده طائره الاف 16 بكل
بساطه خلال ثواني تم مسحها من السجل
المدني حينما تتحدث عن هذه النماذج
الاطفال والنساء عفوا الذين تم قتلهم بشكل
مباشر اعدامات حدثت الليالي الماضيه تم
نقلها من خلال طبعا تطور وسائل التقنيه
لذلك بتقدير اسرائيل تحاول تغييب الصوره
تقطع الاتصالات تخيل منذ اربعه ايام
الاتصالات مقطوعه تماما عن قطاع غزه
بالحويه او عبر الانترنت لانه لا يريد
للصوره الفلسطينيه ان تنقل الى العالم
وهذا جزء من صراع الصوره ما بين صوره
المجاز الي يرتكب بها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وما ما بين محاوله الجيش الاسرائيلي ردع
الفلسطينيين عن مقاومته او التصدي له نعم
في حرب الصوره هذه دكتور لقاء مكي في
النهايه ما يهم هو تاثير ذلك على اصحاب
القرار السياسي نعم يعني الشباب في الدول
الغربيه من الامريكيين والاوروبيين و دعنا
من الشباب العربي في في المقيم هناك
الشباب الغربي وهذه المظاهرات في النهايه
لقائل ان يسال ما تاثيرها في النهايه على
صاحب الق في الولايات المتحده او في
الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك تاثير يعني التاثير
طبعا الان الولايات المتحده لم يكن لها ان
تضغط على اسرائيل للانتهاء من مرحله القصف
المكثف الى مرحله اخرى لولا هذا الضغط
الذي يجري الان ووصل تاثيره الى الحزب
الديمقراطي الحاكم والى الحمله الانتخابيه
المقبله لبايدن كذلك في الغرب وهذا اللي
حدث عنه بايدن بان اسرائيل فقدت الدعم
الغربي لانه الراي العام يضغط على حكامه
وهناك كثير من الحكومات اصبحت تخشى حتى
على مقاعدها الانتخابات المقبله في
بلدانها هناك متغيرات مهمه تجري ورايد
المتغيرات المستقبليه اهم من المتغيرات
الحاليه الراهنه على صعيد القضيه
الفلسطينيه ولكن ولكن اسمح لي اسرائيل لا
تبدو عابئ على الاطلاق يعني اخر تصريحات
نتنياهو او جانس او غير نحن سنذهب وسننتصر
وسنقضي على حماس وكذا وكذا بالتالي في
النهايه ما الترجمه العمليه لكل ما كنا
نتحدث عنه استاذ محمد الحرب الصوره لن
تحسب المعارك لكنها تضع
صوره لنتيجه المعارك هي يعني لا تحسم
معركه المعركه تحسم في الميدان وتحسم على
طاوله المفاوضات اما الصوره التي تنتج عن
الميدان او عن المعركه و عن الحرب
السياسيه حتى فهي تخلق انطباعات ومخي
ورؤيه وتراكم وتراكم ولا يمكن ان نعتمد
عليها كليا في عمليه الانتاج
انتاج البساطات او الصفقات النهائيه في
لان هناك امور اخرى متعلقه بالصفقات غير
الصوره امور قد ت تبدل العلن يعني سياسيه
وامور اخرى غير معروفه تتعلق بصفقات
داخليه لذلك حتى نتنياهو التاييد الداخلي
له في اسرائيل مهم جدا في عمليه القرار
التي يتخذه يعني ائتلاف الحاكم الرؤيه
السياسيه الى اخره حت حتى حتى الانكفاء
العربي ربما عن عن عن المضي قدما في موضوع
التطبيع ايضا سيلعب دورا الضغوط العربيه
رغم انه ان للاسف يعني يبدو انه ليس هناك
ضغوط عربيه فاعله في هذا الجانب شكرا لك
دكتور لقاء مكي شكرا لك دكتور بلال
الشوبكي وشكرا لك سيد اياد القار كعاده
تغطيتنا مستمره سواء للتطورات الميدانيه
او لل السياسيه